back over to you Christian what do you
have for us well we have a guest guys
Justin Wang is with us one of uh the
biggest Victors of today's round Justin
first of all big congratulations you
just uh took out the top seed of the
event how does that feel thank you
I mean uh
I'm not sure exactly how it feels but I
mean
I guess maybe someone I'd say someone's
strange results I was well I was like no
like only I only in the end I think the
position might be winning might be
winning but I mean obviously I thought I
was defending defending the entire game
and probably
probably lost at some point but it was
definitely a topsy uh third of the event
is this the highest rated player that
you beat in your career
I'm not sure well I think well
uh well I think I'd be well I mean
another player like uh close to his
level yeah I don't know it's like
slightly higher radio I believe but
excellent well let's talk about this
game because it was quite a crazy game
he started off with his King's Indian
approach did you feel like he's trying
to put some pressure on you with the
black pieces well I mean I mean yeah I
mean I was thinking like he like just
he was playing like this uh like
I don't know like more
I guess like in line with some more we
play I'd say but it might also
it might also give white some Advantage
but I have not really
uh like I probably have not really
utilized the advantage from the opening
so
uh you mentioned at the beginning that
you thought he was close to winning or
at least putting a lot of pressure was
that particular moment that you felt he
is gaining some momentum I don't know
like I mean well I mean so maybe
starting with like the queen D2 F4 I
mean I just complete I just completely
misfy basically this idea of f4 again
and then I thought you could just take
but then you can also play E4 and then I
mean
maybe my position is pretty bad but
well I mean I'm not sure about the
evaluation but it started it's something
might have went wrong but I mean like
I saw like Queen H4 Queen if we will
give one
like if you play Queen of three
to do but I don't know like
instead of Queen F5 perhaps Queen to F3
what did you well maybe I shouldn't Miss
maybe it's a mistake but I mean I I was
thinking Rook F1 Queen E2 and then I did
not really see a weird clear way to
defend but
I mean then then if I play Rook like
Rook fv1 then they play they could play
Queen B2 I believe but I mean it could
be two and I have I have no clue what to
play but I mean I thought Queen takes A2
at least I have Bishop D4 but after here
Bishop to D4 if Queen takes day two I'm
not sure well maybe it's just extremely
unclear but I thought
you're getting some counter chances he
decided against this he decided to go
Queen to F5 and then we got to this very
crucial point in our estimation at least
Bishop to D4 let's keep going and that
Queen to H5 move after Knight to E3
let's keep going
Oh you mean if I yeah I mean after I
play King age who won and then complete
Point H5 but it's just
yeah unfortunately they have the
and this particular moment this is where
we switched to your game and we saw you
making this very crucial move Queen to
H5 how did you assess the position at
this point I don't know I mean well I
mean basically I just kind of I'm just
trying to find some move like which
design like well which doesn't lose the
game I say but but at this point you
were better actually did you feel that
way no
I'm not sure if I was better I mean I
was probably not really caring about the
evaluation at that point because like
it's more like not blundering something
because like like I mean I was
calculating 194 Rook G4 for example
instead of like on the queen H5 move
like
194 rookie for
the queen takes H6 queen of five and I
have no clue what to do really yeah that
might be bad news for you well
yeah so I mean just try to find a move
that does not like well you found it
because Queen H5 is the best movie in
the position
yeah but this was another big moment can
we go back just before D3 okay it's not
losing no no no by any means Queen to C3
did you consider Queen takes F6 what
were you worried about after Queen takes
F6
yeah
[Music]
Queen to E6
oh okay
okay yeah okay
I never saw Queen A6 in a calculation
but
so this was the blind spot okay now we
understand the queen d8 K7 note tracks
and it was still a wide position after
root to D3 you're not worse or anything
of that nature uh he did have this move
Rook to G1 yeah rookie one I mean yeah
it's the Trident defending against
rookie when I was considering Queen D3
instead and but that review on the
problem so I thought I thought white
should be fine here at least but
absolutely like he and then I think like
well oh he has rookie too okay well Rook
G3 rookie two
thing I'm not sure it's just it seems
like the game will finish in some sort
of a Perpetual at this point but he
played this queen to B4 and after that
you just took over
oh yeah
yeah uh yeah I don't I don't know like
Queen B4 Queen B5
I mean I was not sure what like like
what the point of the move was but I
mean well you guys were kind of playing
on increments so yeah I mean
it's not easy to handle this type of uh
complicated position with only seconds
on the clock Justin
against a Wonder Liang will let you go
back to your hotel room get some rest
get some preparation going and we'll see
you tomorrow yeah okay thank you our
congratulations indeed for upsetting uh
the number one seed and while he was
nervous and uh questioning his moves he
played a really good game they're good
moves they were good my question though
they were very good indeed they were